hi guys today we have an exciting video
on the looks of by-elections today we
will perform Twitter sentiment analysis
and find out what is the emotion of
India the 17th parliamentary election
who will form the government in 2019
let's find out the mood of the nation
with so much happening in Indian
politics in the last two months many
people believe that India's future will
be decided on the 23rd of May 2019 the
judgement day of the Lok Sabha elections
over the years there have been two major
parties in India who've been fighting to
shape India's future the Indian National
Congress and the Bharatiya janta party
now that all the faces of the elections
are over the exit polls average predicts
that the bjp-led NDA will get 312 seats
and the congress-led UPA will get 113
but you must be wondering what people
sentiments are towards these two parties
using Twitter sentiment analysis and art
we will use two comparisons first
between the official handles of the BJP
and the Congress second between the
hashtag Narendra Modi and hashtag Rahul
Gandhi then we'll compare the emotions
of the tweets which people have tweeted
for each of them we would like to say
that simply learned does not endorse any
political party the results the v-- show
are purely based on what people have
tweeted so without further ado let's
jump into our sentiment analysis code
and see who's more likely to win this
Twitter battle we're running this code
on our studio we've already got the code
set up as you can see here first we'll
install all the required packages needed
to perform the analysis we'll start off
by installing the Twitter our package
which provides access to the Twitter API
this is followed up by the library
command which is used for importing the
package you already install the packages
so we'll only be importing it using the
library commands the next package we
shall install is the our curl package
this provides the functions to compose
HTTP requests
fetch URLs get in post forms and so on
this is also used to process the results
returned by the webserver next we will
install the our OAuth package this will
help you authenticate your Twitter
account then we will install a package
for plotting and visualization which is
called the ggplot2 will then install the
snowball c package that implements
porters word stemming algorithm for the
comparison of vocabulary next we'll
install the stringer package which is
you
for string operations then the word
cloud package will help you create for
cloud comparisons will use the TM
package which is used to perform text
mining in are the duplicate which is a
popular data manipulation package in our
and the are color blue a package that
provides you with different color
schemes which you can use for your
visualizations then we'll install the
package HTT R which is used for working
with URLs and H gdb and finally we will
install the most important package of
them all the soo-ji now this will help
you extract sentiments and sentiment
derived plots from text now we'll access
the keys and tokens of my Twitter
account by logging into developer
twitter.com I have already logged in but
you can go into the keys and tokens tab
here where you can get your consumer API
keys as well as access token and access
token secret keys which you can see here
now we will store all the keys and
tokens and specific variables such as
API key API secret access token an
access token secret now to access my
Twitter account I'll pass
all of the above credentials into this
function now this function will help me
connect my Twitter account to our our
next step is to extract the tweets from
the official handle of BJP now first
we're using the function search Twitter
we're taking into consideration
BJP x' official Twitter handle which is
at BJP for india and taking into
consideration dates from the 15th of May
all the way to the 21st of May which is
today we're taking into consideration
5,000 tweets all of which are in the
English language we loading them up into
the variable BJP underscore tweets - now
this extraction process might take a
while so we will wait now that that's
done we work start to the tweets and now
we need to store these tweets or to a
data frame this is made possible with
the function TW list - DF by passing the
variable BJP underscore tweets - now
this is loaded into another way table
which is BJP underscore tweets - dot DF
which is meaning that it's a data frame
and now that that's done we'll use the
head function to show the first 6 tweets
taken from this data frame and there you
have it here are the first 6 tweets
taken from the BJP underscore tweets -
data frame now in this next step will be
removing hashtags John characters are
the Twitter handles and URLs from the
tags using the jisub function after this
we can use these tweets for further
analysis now here you can see we're
removing spaces retweets punctuation
digits are the websites emojis and so on
and in this step we calculate the
emotional score of each tweet here we
use the get underscore NRC underscore
sentiment function to categorize the
tweets into ten different emotions like
positive negative anger fear and so on
next the columns function is used to sum
up all the emotions of a particular
category in the emo some variable we
store the count of each tweet under a
particular motion and finally with the
factor function we can calculate the
categorical distribution of data and
sort them in decreasing order of emotion
now we're ready to visualize the results
as to what type of emotions are dominant
in these tweets will import the plotly
library and then use the plotly function
to show a bar graph as shown here now
the x-axis shows emotions the y-axis
shows the count and the colors vary
depending on the emotions now this graph
will be called emotion for BJP now we'll
be executing the P variable to plot the
graph now let's have a look at this
graph now let's zoom in into this graph
here you can see a bar graph with
different emotions on the x-axis and the
count on the y-axis and here you can
clearly see that the positive emotions
towards BJP is almost at 4,000 they
trust is at 2,000 the negative emotions
are at thousand seven hundred and
likewise for other emotions you can also
create a word cloud for all the words
present in the tweets and classify them
into different categories of emotions
like this now as you can see here the
words have been classified into
different categories of emotions now if
you want to learn about how we created
this word cloud let us know in the
comments section below we'll be more
than happy to share the code file with
you now we perform the same sentiment
analysis on the Congress's official
twitter handle at I&C India and these
were the results here we can see the
negative emotion towards Congress is
close to 3,000 positive emotions
slightly cross 2500 and the trust is
slightly about 2,000 we can compare this
with BJP with the positive emotions are
close to 4,000 the trust is at 2,000 and
the negative emotions slightly cross
2500 similarly you can compare the other
emotional categories between BJP and
Congress we also took into consideration
two very important hashtags related to
the selection
hashtag Narendra Modi as well as hashtag
Rahul Gandhi these are the respective
results for Narendra Modi the positive
motion is more than 3,500 the trust is
slightly about 2,000 and the negative
emotions are slightly about 2500 with
Rahul Gandhi the positive emotions are
almost a 2,500 the trust is also almost
up to 2500 and the negative emotions are
almost 2500 now that we've finished with
the analysis the results obtained
indicate that the number of tweets
showing positive emotion for the BJP and
Narendra Modi is higher than that of
Congress and on Gandhi so the chances of
the BJP and its allies returning to
power for a second term is well within
reach but there are other regional
parties which could play a major role in
deciding who would form the next
government so let's see what really
happens on the 23rd of May the judgement
day we hope you found this analysis
informative and helpful thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simpler hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here